馬斯克要對半導體出手了
他帶來的新概念
會顛覆半導體產業嗎
大家都知道
半導體製造對潔淨度的要求近乎病態
工程師必須穿上這件
叫兔寶寶裝的無塵衣
才能進到無塵室中
蛤 為什麼不是女僕裝
就是不行
但 Elon Musk 2026年初提出
完全不同的構想
他理想中的 2 奈米髒工廠中
自己能穿著便服 吃著漢堡
甚至大抽雪茄
晶圓廠還能正常運作
這
到底是天才般的成本革命
還是完全不懂半導體製程實務的
門外漢狂言呢
今天 我們就來拆解
馬斯克的這場豪賭
首先 馬斯克這次挑戰的重點
為什麼是無塵室呢
不過關於無塵室
我們2025年8月就討論過這個問題
但這次的重點是成本
大家知道半導體的製程
要在無塵室中進行
因為現在半導體的材料寬度
已經來到數奈米到數十奈米的寬度
你想 就算是一顆粒徑
只有1微米的粒子掉落在元件上
那也是材料的數百倍大
只要沾黏上去
元件很有可能直接短路 失效
當然 無塵室中不可能完全乾淨
我們需要的是工業化的標準
傳統美國聯邦標準的無塵室等級
會在Class後面加一個數字
這個數字代表室內
每一立方英尺的空間中
能容忍多少粒徑大於0.5微米的
粒子數量
例如Class 100的無塵室
代表室內每一立方英尺內
微粒數量不能大於100顆
後來國際間則有根據
ISO 14644之1訂定的新標準
把無塵室從1到9進行分級
ISO的第三級 Class 3
大約同等美國標準的Class 1
比起美國標準
又多了更嚴格的
ISO Class 1跟Class 2
另外 微粒也不只看0.5微米的粒子
而是同時監測多種粒徑
最小則以0.1微米作為主要標準
例如ISO最嚴格的第一級
每立方公尺的空間中
0.1微米的粒子要少於10顆
0.2微米的要少於2顆
一般來說
不同工業有不同的無塵需求標準
食品業大約在ISO Class 7
生技業因為分子較大
大約在5到7級
最細小的半導體
則在3到5 甚至更低
而麻煩的就在這
熱力學第二定律告訴我們
萬物 尤其是空氣 懸浮微粒
這種可以四處移動的粒子
傾向於混亂
也就是說 就算我們沒有任何
人為活動攜帶污染源進入無塵室
放著不動
髒空氣也會想方設法擴散進無塵室中
為了抵抗這種自然現象
我們自然需要消耗能源來搬運這些粒子
沒錯 一切都是熱力學
各家半導體廠
包括台積電的超大晶圓廠 GIGAFAB
整座廠房的天花板
佈滿了風機濾網機組
協助廠內持續換氣
這換氣當然不是裝個空調就好
在半導體廠中
連空氣的流向都要很講究
常見的作法
會以垂直層流設計
讓空氣穩定速度垂直向下流動
將所有的污染
包含機械運轉或人員衣物摩擦
產生的碎屑微粒 通通帶走
這空氣的流速
可是經過流體力學的精確計算
首先 它的動能要比因為機台發熱
讓空氣向上對流的熱浮力還要大
但是流速也不能太快
要不然容易出現混亂的空氣流動狀態
也就是湍流
空氣會在機台的角落旋轉
髒污全部聚積在這邊
在流體力學中
可以透過計算雷諾數
來判斷穩定的層流
是否容易變成湍流
雷諾數代表流體慣性力與黏滯力的比值
簡單來說 這就像是群飛的候鳥
黏滯力代表與周圍同伴的互動
慣性力代表外來的影響
例如風速或天敵
當雷諾數小
就代表候鳥傾向遵循團隊的飛行
而非外來刺激
整團鳥群更能穩定向前飛行
在無塵室的氣流中
流體的黏滯係數越高 流速越慢
雷諾數都會降低
這代表流體流動穩定
不容易出現湍流
最後 任何人員或機器產生的微粒
都會被這股均勻的氣流抓住
並直接進入地板的孔洞中
因為空氣只有上下移動
能有效防止髒污橫向擴散
污染其他機台晶圓
哇 只是換個氣
就要考慮機台的發熱
機台的擺放位置和一堆流體力學
無塵室內真的是
各種科學的極致融合
蛤 要不要放乖乖啊
這還是要放的
但你想 要維持這麼大的空間
24小時不斷吹出這樣的空氣
電費跟維護費有多恐怖
我們之前的影片提到過
龐大的空氣循環系統
精密的溫濕度控制
以及為了冷卻空氣的冰水系統
就佔了整座工廠能源成本的
約30%到40%
所以馬斯克才認為
現代晶圓廠在無塵室的設計上
搞錯了方向
如果我們能縮小範圍
讓所有晶圓都在局部的設備內維持無塵
就不需要蓋那麼大的無塵室啦
能省下巨大成本
還能在工廠內吃漢堡 抽雪茄
但 這方法真的可行嗎
馬斯克這樣說
晶圓應該在整個生產過程中
始終處於完全密封
放入正壓的氮氣微型環境中
確保髒污不會進入機台
嗯 其實馬斯克的想法並不是新鮮事
而且半導體業界早就在這麼做了
只是現在正挑戰將其推向極致
現代晶圓廠已經大量使用
前開式晶圓傳送盒 FOUP
晶圓在機器之間移動時
確實是密封在盒子裡的
在早期的8吋晶圓廠時代
晶圓是露放在環境中的
因此整個廠房必須維持極高的潔淨度
而 FOUP 則是專為
12吋晶圓設計的標準傳送容器
門開在側面
讓自動化機械手臂
能以水平方向直接抽取晶圓
FOUP 這個盒子呢
本身由導電型碳酸聚酯製成
裡頭含有碳纖維或抗靜電劑
可以透過接地把塑膠上的靜電消除
防止靜電產生吸附微粒
而且碳酸聚酯
是一種含有苯環的長鏈聚合物
這種結構分子間的作用力強
相對於其他塑膠
在製程溫度下
這些長鏈分子不容易斷裂成
微小氣體分子污染晶圓
這種特性稱為低出氣性
FOUP 還有個關鍵設計
它的底部設有充氣孔與排氣孔
當 FOUP 停留在設備或儲存倉時
系統會注入高純度氮氣
將內部的氧氣與水分趕走
確保維持在ISO Class 1的水準
當 FOUP 移動時
則靠高氣密性維持空氣潔淨
至於機台與機台間的移動
則靠空中行走式無人搬送車 OHT
用時速10到15公里的速度
將 FOUP 從一台機台送至下一個機台
最後呢
FOUP 會先被送進設備前端模組 EFEM
EFEM 是晶圓從運輸狀態
進入加工狀態的唯一轉運站
裡頭當然也是 Class 1 的環境
機械手臂會打開 FOUP
將晶圓一片片取出
並用正確的角度
把晶圓送進曝光機或蝕刻機
沒錯
從一個機台穿梭至下一個機台
我們幾乎都能維持在極致乾淨
且封閉的環境下完成
那麼 我們不就不需要無塵室了嗎
以現在的製程狀況
因為 FOUP 這種局部潔淨環境的存在
在無塵室中的其他地方
例如走道
我們需要的乾淨等級已經可以放寬一些了
例如 Class 5 或 Class 6
但 要在機台旁邊抽雪茄
還有幾個關鍵要克服
首先 FOUP 需要打開
與其他設備相接
因此在開口需要有氣密條
現在這個材料
通常選用全氟化彈性體 FFKM
化學式長這樣
它的碳鏈上面的氫原子
幾乎全部由氟原子取代
碳氟鍵是有機化學中最強的單鍵之一
原因在於氟原子體積小 電負度極高
能與碳形成極度穩定的鍵結
使外界能量與化學反應
都很難把它拆開
因此全氟化結構
通常都有超高的化學穩定性
這 FFKM 幾乎能抵抗所有化學品的侵蝕
不會隨意釋放氣體分子
同時還具有彈性
但但但 無塵室內和外的環境
可說是天差地遠
無塵室內本來顆粒就少
氣密材料只要負責抵擋空氣就好
但你直接站在旁邊抽雪茄
全氟化彈性體是有機高分子材料
雪茄的煙霧也是各種有機分子組成
焦油 尼古丁
各種揮發性有機物也是有機分子
全氟化彈性體雖然具有
高度化學穩定性
但在分子尺度上仍是一種
具有自由體積的高分子網狀結構
而煙霧這些尺寸小
極性低的有機分子
不會被材料表面明顯排斥
容易先在表面累積
接著在濃度梯度的驅動下
緩慢滲入材料內部並向另一側擴散
如果時間久了
有機物就會緩緩滲進材料中
緩緩地往低濃度的地方
也就是向材料的另一頭擴散
最後進到 FOUP 中
現實是
目前的 FOUP 可以擋住灰塵
但它無法完全隔絕化學氣體
空氣中的揮發性有機物 酸鹼氣體
甚至水分
都會透過 FOUP 的塑膠殼壁
或密封墊片慢慢滲透進去
還有啊
雖然晶圓看起來
是在密閉空間中進行的
但是每一次不同設備的設備接口對接
每一次打開艙口
一瞬間的壓力差
都會在艙口引起小小的湍流
將外部微粒帶入
你想想 如果這些箱子在移動過程中
開口就沾滿了灰塵
打開的瞬間 真的能確保乾淨嗎
要記得
幾顆灰塵就可能直接摧毀整片晶圓
重要的是
無塵室的存在
不只是提供無塵環境這個任務而已
乾燥 乾淨 恆溫的空氣
和無塵室的精密設計
可以確保所有機台溫度 濕度
氣流都具備穩定性
把靜電 濕度 設備震動的影響
都降到最小
這一切是為了避免那個最現實的問題
那就是半導體設備需要定期拆解維修
或更換零件
如果設備周遭是普通空氣
當工程師打開腔體的那一刻
裡面的潔淨環境
會立刻被灰塵與水分污染
後續重新清潔與抽真空的時間成本
將會讓晶圓廠崩潰
所以
我們可以宣告馬斯克的想法
是天真的胡說八道了嗎
也不是
馬斯克的目標是值得努力的
畢竟空調設備
就是會佔3到4成的能源成本
他們甚至不像 EUV 曝光機
人家耗電是為了有產出啊
但以現實角度來說
比起冒著各種污染風險
在所有機器外頭罩上一個大型無塵室
仍是優先選擇
馬斯克的想法並非空談
但還需要投入成本與時間來開發技術
而這 不只是馬斯克
而是所有半導體廠都在努力的方向
例如剛才說湍流會帶入微粒
現代 EFEM 其實也有應對方案
正壓氣簾
當 FOUP 門打開時
設備會主動向外噴射
極高速的潔淨氮氣
用動能抵消擴散
FOUP 也正升級為 E-FOUP
它內置的感測器
能即時監控內部的溼度
氧氣濃度與微粒數量
如果偵測到異常
它會立刻發出警報
甚至啟動內建的微型過濾系統
但我們也可以想想
或許最後的解方
在不同的技術上
也就是機器人
既然人類是最大的熱源
污染源和靜電來源
那就乾脆把人踢出去
這就是所謂的關燈工廠
雖然現在的台積電12吋廠
自動化程度已經極高
能靠著無人搬送車
包辦幾乎所有的晶片搬運工作
但 OHT 的軌道是固定的
能做的事情也是固定的
當機台需要維修 保養 抽樣檢查
安裝新儀器
仍然需要活人進無塵室處理
這時候如果有機器人可以包辦所有其餘工作
或是當人類遠端操控的 Avatar
欸 目標是就算地震發生
機台與管線的安全確認
參數校準 機台復位
都能自動化或靠機器人完成
讓工程師不用一天到晚加班
就算我們仍需要一個無塵室
包住所有設備
提供穩定的環境
但至少這個全面由機器人進駐的無塵室
裡頭的機器擺放
可以在人類不用頻繁進出的前提下
重新設計
甚至垂直堆疊
讓無塵室的體積縮到最小
你覺得呢
你覺得最後決勝負的關鍵技術會是什麼
創造過許多奇蹟的馬斯克
會成為新的半導體代工霸主嗎
留言告訴我們吧
你也可以先點這裡複習
半導體廠的空調為什麼那麼耗電
也可以點這裡
花兩個半小時看懂晶片戰爭
記得訂閱 PanSci 泛科學頻道
開啟小鈴鐺
加入我們的頻道會員
鎖定更多精彩的科學新知 科學議題
我們下次再見